this video is sponsored by Squarespace
the One-Stop shop that lets you make a
website of your very own to engage with
your audience and then Spruce it up with
pretty effects and layouts and even sell
your merch on there like socks if you're
selling socks if you've ever wanted to
make a website that you can call your
own then I highly suggest following in
my footsteps and giving Squarespace a
try especially if you're into making
gaming content you can even check out my
fantastic new website in the description
if you fancy they've got tons of super
easy templates to work off of if you
need some inspiration and extremely cool
ways to host your content on the website
or embed any video anywhere and even
remonetize it all all 100 through your
website on Squarespace and stay on top
of your website visits with their
insightful analytics so you know exactly
how many people are visiting from where
and even better you can try Squarespace
out for free for 14 days then when
you're ready to launch your amazing new
site you can head to squarespace.com
Bandit for 10 off the first purchase so
what are you waiting for
hey guys it's me Bandit I know it's been
a little while since my last upload but
things have happened I randomly woke up
in New York City for instance but of
course you would have known that if you
followed me on Instagram but anyway I'm
back and wanted to start the year off
fresh with covering Zelda as in the
princess from the series The Legend of
Zelda you may think you know all there
is to know about the well-known princess
who gives Toadstool a run for her money
in the how many times can you be
kidnapped competition but think again
for instance did you know that unlike
the spirit of the hero Zelda is more of
a descendant than a reincarnation and
every daughter born into the original
Zelda's bloodline after a certain point
in the timeline was to be named Zelda
meaning technically there have been an
infinite unknowable number of zeldas
that we've never even met or how about
the fact that at one point there were
two completely different princess zeldas
alive and in existence at the same time
in the same timeline oh yeah zeldalore
goes hard and that my friends is the
name of the game for this video so
without further Ado let us delve into
explaining each iteration of Zelda that
we know of in the games oh and spoiler
alert for the in entire franchise
obviously since it's easier to explain
in Universe lore when following the
in-universe lore timeline we're going to
cover the Zelda appearances in the order
they take place on the timeline starting
with the very first Zelda from Skyward
Sword this Zelda is different from every
other Zelda in that she's not actually
royalty well not yet at least since the
royal family exists immediately
following this game and is composed of
her descendants it can be assumed that
Skyward Zelda started the Royal Family
when she and Link probably you know
populated the surface of the Earth but
anyway it was due to the Events and
Adventures surrounding Skyward Zelda's
life that we were able to discover her
true identity and that is that she is
The Reincarnation of the goddess hylia
who is probably the goddess of time but
that's a whole other Theory and
therefore her bloodline is not only
Royal but is literally Supernatural and
yes her Supernatural blood gives her and
her descendants super powers she's the
full package but besides her return to
the surface and the founding of Hyrule
there's not much else to say about Good
Old Skyward Zelda so moving on the next
Zelda that pops up on the timeline is
the princess from the Minish Cap we'll
call her Minish Zelda now Minish Zelda
serves to kind of throw a wrench in the
whole Zelda's having powers due to
highly a bloodline thing because Minish
Zelda has a presumably different Power
flowing through her veins according to
vati the main enemy of the game see long
ago the teeny tiny little Minish people
descended down to the land of
regular-sized people and gave the
ancient hylians a magical power called
the light Force this light Force which
originated not from hylia but from Tiny
Sky people was similarly placed within
the bloodline of hyrule's princess and
is said to be a source of Limitless
magical power so just to be clear at
this point in the timeline princess
zeldas have both goddess powers and the
unlimited source of magical power called
the light force in their bloodlines I
suppose a theory could be made that
they're one and the same but well maybe
I'll talk more about that in another
video hint hint wink wink subscribe back
to Minish Zelda though besides the whole
light force in her blood thing the only
other chewy piece of lore that she gives
to the series would be the fact that she
is the first Princess Zelda and that's
about it the next Princess Zelda is the
Zelda from four Swords similarly to the
previous two she also was a childhood
friend of her link and helps link defeat
vati once again who tried to marry her
yup the next Princess Zelda is one of
the most important if not V de facto
most important Zelda to the lore of the
franchise and I'm not just saying that
because Ocarina of Time is my favorite
game of all time okay maybe I am a
little bit but seriously she has a very
fleshed out story and is also literally
the reason why the timeline splits in
the first place well she's the reason
why it splits between adult and child
that is the Fallen timeline exists
either way but we don't explain that
when using actual logic anyway Ocarina
Zelda who is also the same Zelda that
kind of makes an appearance in Majora's
Mask is the first Zelda who alongside
the hero of time we get to see both as a
child and as an adult and in both
instances she kind of sort of messes
everything up despite trying her hardest
to do the right thing hashtag relatable
I go into this in much more detail in an
old video of mine I did explaining
Ocarina Zelda's big mistake but in a
nutshell as a child she was given
prophetic dreams which detailed Evil
coming to the world and a boy in green
being the key to saving everyone in an
attempt to do something with her Visions
she tried to bring it up to her father
who apparently didn't listen to her some
that Kings of Hyrule have in common with
one another apparently since her father
lent her no ear she took matters into
her own hands when link the weird green
forest boy from her dreams randomly came
to see her she tells link to get the
master sword which he does which ends up
putting link to sleep for seven years
and leaving the door to the sacred realm
and therefore the Triforce wide freaking
open allowing Ganondorf to just Waltz
right in and touch it with his greasy
Gerudo fingers Zelda and impa go into
hiding for seven years and in that time
Zelda trains hard to become an epic
gender swap chica ninja named Chic in
order to thwart ganondorf's best efforts
to find her anyway once link has awoken
from his Slumber seven years later and
is Guided by Zelda I mean Chic towards
the ultimate goal of Awakening all the
sages Sheik reveals himself as the
Princess Zelda herself and immediately
gets captured by Ganondorf after which
link rescues her and normally this is
where a happily ever after would come
into play but not for Ocarina Zelda see
she was so racked with guilt over the
whole link losing his childhood in the
world being plunged into seven long
years of war horribleness thing since
really it was kind of her fault that it
all happened so to rectify what she
could for link she decides to send him
back to his original timeline removing
the hero of time from the adult timeline
and permanently splitting the timeline
into adult and child and this is where a
multitude of theories take place such as
the rather controversial theory that the
spirit of the hero itself was removed
from the adult timeline because of this
leading to no hero Rising when the world
needed him again when Ganon broke out of
a seal prior to the events of the Wind
Waker or my theory that the master sword
was removed from the adult timeline
because of this leading to another blade
taking its place also in the Wind Waker
anyway we've spent a lot of time
discussing Ocarina Zelda but the last
thing I'll mention is that she has two
existences by the end of the game the
grown-up Ocarina Zelda we see at the end
that lives on in the adult timeline and
probably helps restore Hyrule and the
kid Ocarina Zelda we see at the end that
lives on in the child timeline and gives
link the Ocarina of Time once again
before he goes on his next adventure in
termina moving on we'll cover the adult
timeline Zelda's first since I mentioned
Wind Waker so much Princess Zelda and
the Wind Waker actually has no idea
she's a princess until you're a good
ways into the game and before that she's
a young 12 year old pirate Queen who
went by the name Tetra and inherited a
ship and its crew once her mother the
previous pirate Queen passed away Tetra
as far as we can tell was born at sea
but is obviously a descendant of Ocarina
Zelda and because of this we can
actually see a giant picture of an
ancestor of her lineage down in the
submerged Hyrule Castle a previous Zelda
who also had a crew I guess positioned
around her which mimics the current
pirate crew exactly implying that Tetra
and her crew are all descendants of
these ancestors along with her bloodline
she also carried with her a fragment of
the Triforce of wisdom which had been
passed down from mother to daughter
following the fall of Hyrule and the
flooding of the World As for the events
of the game eventually Tetra now wearing
a dress and going by the name Zelda
helps link defeat Ganondorf and the
world of Hyrule is drowned once and for
all and then Zelda takes off her dress
and goes back to going by the name Tetra
and sails off with link for more
Adventures at Sea she does make a slight
appearance in the game's direct sequel
the Phantom Hourglass where she is
pretty much immediately captured until
the end of the game at which point she
returns to the pirate's life however the
next Zelda in the adult timeline is a
descendant of tetra Zelda who discovered
a new land with link and founded New
Hyrule and the new royal family before
passing away Spirit track Zelda is
specifically tetra's great great
granddaughter and shares a backstory
with the four sword Zona in that she's
been a childhood friend of link and
pulls an Ocarina Zelda by secretly
meeting with Lincoln plotting to
investigate matters without involving
any adults in this case they begin
investigating The Disappearance of the
spirit tracks also she is actually the
first playable Zelda in the franchise
which is a huge milestone for the series
hmm what's that you say you remember
another playable Zelda before Spirit
Tracks Zelda
no you don't that was just a bad dream
anyway Spirit track Zelda also serves as
the game's companion character after
she's uh killed actually well not killed
per se but her soul leaves her body so
you tell me what that means anyway way
bada bing bada boom she and Link kick
all sorts of booty and eventually link
exercises princess Zelda's possessed
body and she's able to regain it after
which they kick the new Demon King
melodus booty and restore order to the
land of new Hyrule together and now the
adult timeline has a happily ever after
ending moving over to the child timeline
the first Zelda to appear in a game
after Ocarina Zelda does in Majora's
Mask would be Twilight Zelda from the
game Twilight Princess now in the child
timeline ganondorf's takeover of Hyrule
was prevented due to link going back in
time and well preventing it however the
Triforce was still split into three
pieces somehow which means that it may
exist outside of the timelines but that
is not a subject I'm willing to get into
right now I said that because in
Twilight Princess the descendants of the
hero of time and Ocarina Zelda both
already have their pieces of the
Triforce in their bloodlines which is
really neither here nor there but I just
wanted to cover it real quick anyway
Twilight Zelda by the time the game
takes place is the sole ruler of Hyrule
which is proven by the fact that when
Zant barges into the throne room to take
it over it's Zelda herself that he
approaches and not a king or a anybody
else which should mean that technically
she should be Queen Zelda so I'm just
gonna call her Queen Zelda from now on
anyway zand forces Queen Zelda to
surrender and thus plunges the world of
Hyrule into Twilight with Zelda being
held prisoner in her own castle which I
guess could be worse All Things
Considered I mean at least she has a
view of the Kingdom that she surrendered
whose inhabitants are now eternally
suffering anyway eventually Link in the
real Twilight Princess named midna
approach Zelda while midna is dying
after zead forcefully plunges her into
the light as a being of Twilight her
life begins to fade very quickly but
just before she takes her last breath
Queens outer decides to sacrifice her
Essence in order to save midna's life
transforming midna from being just a
being of Twilight into a being of both
light and Twilight now I'd like to
interject a little mini theory of mine
regarding how Zelda was able to do this
and dissipate entirely but yet also have
her soulless body show up later in order
to be possessed by Ganondorf I mean if
this was Zelda's body that just
disappeared Into Thin Air what did
Ganondorf just conjure up a new body in
Zelda's image just because he wanted to
possess a Zelda I think not personally I
think the answer is tied to why she's
strangely able to resist turning into a
spirit like all the other hyruleans do
when exposed to Twilight simply put I
think she actually is a spirit here
similar to the other spirits but not
quite see I think that perhaps she was
granted some special protections from
her piece of the Triforce when subjected
to the influence of Twilight just like
link when he was turned into a wolf
instead of a spirit and if you think
about it we already know that the
Triforce pieces protect their bearers
from protect their bearers from Twilight
but act differently when exposed to
Twilight the Triforce of Courage turns
its Bearer into a courageous Beast while
the Triforce of power turns its Bearer
into literally a flaming ball of power
so what if the Triforce of wisdom allows
its Bearer to manifest their Spirit or
their mind's Essence from within their
body in order to still be interacted
with other beings of light or Twilight
what I'm saying is what if Queen Zelda's
body never left the throne room and
we're actually speaking to her Triforce
enabled spirit in the castle tower or or
maybe it's a holographic double of her
body which is something that the sheikah
have been known to do which is why she's
wearing a Chic cloak but you know
regardless after defeating her Ganondorf
possessed body Zelda's Essence leaves
midna and returns to her own body after
which she AIDS Lincoln 25 of the battle
against Ganondorf by shooting him with
light arrows on Horseback once he's
finally dead and gone after the
climactic four-part battle Zelda is seen
saying goodbye to midnight the mirror of
twilight forever and afterwards
presumably returns to her rightful place
at the Throne of Hyrule later on in the
timeline four Swords Adventures takes
place which features the next Zelda once
again it can be assumed that she was
childhood friends with link like the
Zelda from four Swords but like the
Zelda from a link to the past which we
haven't gotten to just yet she is able
to telepathically communicate with link
and asks him to join her at the four
sword sanctuary in order to check up on
what's going on with all the ominous
Clouds Of Darkness covering the land
turns out it was a trap by shadowlink
and vati once again is released upon
link drawing the four sword vati once
again kidnaps a Zelda for the third time
now and Zelda after being rest skied by
link AIDS Link in the feeding Ganon the
end moving over to the Fallen timeline
or as we should call it the alternate
reality in which link dies at the end of
Ocarina of Time the first Zelda that
appears after Ocarina Zelda would be the
prince of Zelda of a link to the past
this Zelda starts off the game by
telepathically communicating with the
members of the Knights of Hyrule which
in this case means link and his uncle
she asks for help because she's been
kidnapped by the wizard Agony who was
trying to sacrifice all of the
descendants of the seven wise men to
undo their seal on Ganon in the Dark
World which he was imprisoned within
after he offed link anyway link is not
able to sell Zelda and she gets
sacrificed straight up which in this
universe means that she gets sent to the
Dark World trapped on top of Death
Mountain she doesn't do too much after
this point because well she can't and
eventually link freeze her and wishes
upon the Triforce for evil to be
dispelled from the land after which
Zelda is able to return to Hyrule this
Zelda is the same Zelda that is
referenced in the Oracle games and even
kidnapped once again go figure if the
games are linked twin rova who
apparently was not killed in the Fallen
timeline is the one who kidnaps Zelda at
this point and attempts to sacrifice her
in order to resurrect their son
Ganondorf link prevents this but they
end up just sacrificing themselves in
order to resurrect a Mindless version of
Ganondorf Ganon who is beaten by link
and once again Zelda is able to return
to Hyrule unscathed but probably
traumatized the next Zelda that pops up
is the Zelda from A Link Between Worlds
who like Twilight Zona rules over her
land alone without a father or a mother
or a Suitor when she first meets link
she is warned about Yuga running around
turning people into paintings and being
generally obnoxious at which point she
tells link to go Warn sahasrilla and
gives him the pendant of Courage which
is one of the three pendants of virtue
necessary for drawing the master sword
from deep within the Lost Woods in this
game and in A Link to the Past she did
this because she had a feeling that they
just might need a hero and boy was she
right because not too long afterwards
Yuga comes for Zelda herself and ends up
kidnapping her by turning her into a
beautiful painting and Yanks her into
Laurel with link following behind and
similarly to Agony from A Link to the
Past Yuga uses Zelda and the rest of the
sages to revive Ganon and then merge
with Ganon forming Yuga again and who
eventually will be defeated by link
Zelda and Hyrule are saved at this point
but before I move on to the next Zelda
in the timeline I'm going to cover the
other Zelda In This Very game and by
that I mean low rules version of Zelda
the princess Hilda who has a lot to do
with the story because she's actually
the one behind yuga's actions honestly
I'm still very impressed with this game
for pulling one over on us like that
Yugo was actually hilled as Court Mage
but I'll get to that in a second see
she's nice for the majority of the game
and quote unquote stops Yuga Ganon from
killing link after link arrives in low
Rule and even serves to telepathically
guide link as he Journeys across both
lands and it isn't until the end of the
game that we finally get upside down
Zelda's backstory Hilda's version of
Hyrule called Low rule used to have its
own Triforce which similarly to hyrule's
Triforce was also brutally fought over
by the low rulian inhabitants differing
from Hyrule however Hilda's ancestors
decided to use use the Triforce to
destroy the Triforce which is the kind
of big brain move that would make Thanos
proud but mistake Laurel can't actually
survive without a Triforce it was never
designed to so Hilda instead searched
for another Triforce and she found one
our Triforce hyrule's Triforce so at the
end of the game she reveals that our
Triforce is what she and Yuga were after
all along and she then steals Zelda's
Triforce of wisdom and summons yug again
and once again who has ganon's Triforce
of power somehow and commands yug again
into straight up kill Link in order to
gain the Triforce of Courage which is
unsuccessful because she forgot Link's
kind of a badass Hilda then asks Yuga
Ganon to give her his piece but uge
again and says okay I hear you but what
if you gave me yours and then he takes
her piece in an act of brutal betrayal
and then turns Hilda into a painting
herself and absorbs her after link
defeats him yet again both Triforce
pieces and Hilda are released from Yuga
ganon's gut hilde then actually starts
to try to attack link but is stopped by
upside downlink also known as ravio the
cowardly rabbit dude after talking with
ravio she finally sees the error in her
ways and sends Link and Zelda back to
Hyrule who in return wish upon hyrule's
Triforce to restore low-roll's Triforce
which is the Zelda Universe equivalent
of wishing for more wishes but the point
is it works and both this Zelda and this
Hilda live happily ever after as far as
we can tell the third to last Zelda in
the series pops up in the next game in
the Fallen timeline the original Legend
of Zelda she's got a bit of a simple
story in that she breaks her Triforce of
wisdom into eight pieces and scatters
them across the land in order to hide
them from Ganon who has been resurrected
by his followers prior to the events of
the game yeah that keeps happening
someone should do something about that
she sends her handmaiden impa out to
look for a hero impa finds a 10 year old
with a sword and goes hey you know what
that could work and thus enlists the
child known as Link in the service of
saving the world Ganon reaches Zelda in
the meantime and imprisons her
underneath Death Mountain where she
waits until the end of the game when
link saves her and in her gratitude she
says thanks link you're the hero of
Hyrule
moving on the next game and last game in
the child timeline is the adventure of
Link which takes place six years after
the previous game and technically
features the same Princess Zelda
although she never actually makes an
appearance due to you know ruling Hyrule
and all that however the entire point of
Link's journey in this game is to find
and awaken an ancient Sleeping Princess
Zelda who is the next Zelda that I'll be
talking about now Sleeping Beauty Zelda
was the princess of Hyrule long ago when
it was ruled by her father and following
her father's death her brother the
prince it is said that her father used
the Triforce for good and made Hyrule
all nice and peachy but after he died he
decided for whatever reason to not tell
his son where to find the entire
Triforce but told his daughter Zelda
instead I guess she was the favorite
Child at this point some random wizard
perhaps even another residual Alter Ego
of Ganon appears and tells the prince
that his sister knows where the other
pieces are at which point both The
Prince and the wizard angrily question
Zelda but the stubborn Sleeping Beauty
gives them nothing likely out of fear
that the triforce's ultimate wishing
power would be misused which is a
healthy fear however the wizard got
upset and places Zelda into an eternal
Slumber and then dies after casting the
spell this was not at all what the
prince wanted to happen because after
all he loved his sister and therefore
this made him pretty upset and it's
because of this very story that he being
the new king of Hyrule decreed that all
daughters Born Into The Royal lineage
would therefore be named Zelda anyway
that being said eventually link saves
her and wakes her up from her ancient
sleep and she says you saved Hyrule and
you are a real hero then they kiss and
you cannot convince me otherwise the
most notable thing about the existence
of Sleeping Beauty Zelda to me is the
fact that at this point in time there
are legitimately two princess zeldas
alive at the same time this one and the
one from the previous game who's
currently ruling Hyrule the question is
following the adventure of Link doesn't
this mean that there are now two Royal
Family Lines I mean come on did nobody
at Nintendo really think this one
through did they forget somehow I doubt
we will ever get an answer to that the
final Prince of Zelda in the series
would be the one and only Zelda of the
wild from breath of the wild now this
Zelda is probably the most popular of
all the zeldas on account of her being
from the most popular Zelda game of all
time and because of that I'll just
briefly touch on her story since most of
you probably know all there is to know
about her by now in a shell of a nut she
was as every Zelda before her besides
Skyward Zelda born a princess of Hyrule
but unlike her mother and presumably all
the other females of the Royal Line she
was never able to unlock the powers of
her bloodline this caused her to try to
find other ways to Aid the land of
Hyrule and thus she partnered closely
with her sheika friends it became
somewhat of a scientist herself she even
went so far as to lead the five chosen
hyrulean Champions who were each chosen
to Pilot a Divine Beast following the
prophecy of ganon's return and the
discovery of the ancient chica
automations however she never stopped
trying to unlock her powers people like
her father and the influence of the all
too successful link who was the same age
as her didn't let her forget if anything
it just added to her overall stress poor
thing it wasn't until Calamity Ganon
finally reared its ugly head on her 17th
birthday of all days and after everyone
she knew had died except for link that
her powers finally unlocked in order to
save Link's life at the very last second
it's called love people anyway after
that she sends link off to the shrine of
Resurrection where it spends 100
freaking years rebuilding his body and
goes off to Hyrule Castle herself to
contain Calamity Ganon until link
revives and is able to you know be a
hero telepathically communicating with
him all the while link does indeed kick
Calamity booty and Zelda is able to seal
it away using the last of her power she
did have a 100 Year run with it though
so I'm sure she's good for now following
the events of breath of the wild
apparently the Chica machine stopped
working such as varuta and presumably
Link and Zelda set off to investigate
and we have now officially fully
explained every Zelda and even alternate
universe Zelda there is in the franchise
all the way until Zelda of the Wild's
upcoming appearance in tears of the
kingdom of course but the only thing we
know about her in game so far is that
she's rocking a new haircut and also she
might be dead I'm looking forward to
finding out in just over 100 days though
if you're looking forward to finding out
and if you're still watching then please
consider pressing that like button
because this video was a ton of work and
it would really help it get spread
around on YouTube better and if you're
planning on picking up tears of the
Kingdom make sure you're subscribed if
you haven't already because there's
going to be coverage on the channel oh
yeah tons of coverage huge thanks as
always to my Bandit crew for supporting
my videos I could not do this without
you and that's all I've got for this one
if you want to have all links explained
click the link in the description
otherwise follow me on my socials like
Instagram where I'm going to be doing a
giveaway real soon and this is Bandit
looking forward to seeing you in the
next one and signing out peace
[Music]
thank you